this adam toledo thing is really really
disturbing this young
kid who has a few wacky nicknames
uh andy no but what are andy knows
nicknames
how about that andy knows that
the guy uh the asian guy who keeps going
into
antifa rallies and uh
you know with like a nazi armband and
starts like twerking and then they beat
him up and then he puts his
face everywhere uh
so andy noe has said that uh deceased
teen adam toledo his friends referred to
him as little homicide and baby diablo
well so what it doesn't matter
he dropped the gun and then he put his
hands up and the cop shot him
the cop said drop the gun he dropped the
gun he put his hands up and the cop shot
him
we understand he didn't win the spelling
bee
we get it andy no
we understand this kid was not
an honorable student we get it he didn't
come from the best home
we get it we understand that
cops have to
understand that there's gonna be
blowback
when people see a video of a child with
his hands up being
shot it doesn't matter that the kid was
uh
called baby diablo
i mean we're making this kid into osama
bin laden now
that's what we're gonna do they called
him liu
homicide what
was he just running through the streets
of chicago just wasting people
how many cops did he kill how many
people did baby diablo whack
he's a young mentally challenged kid
with no guidance
in his life okay
and other older members of the gang
exploited him
and brought him out
and you know more about this case than i
do
now is this true and i don't know if
this is true because
why are you laughing i didn't say i'm
talking about something seriously
i'm cheating you're you're making it a
joke and it's not a joke
i'm not here to joke around okay i heard
i heard
i heard that he was dm'd by james
charles oh god
i heard that am i wrong
i heard that james charles dm'd him and
said
what up baby diablo
i heard they call you little homicide
cause you kill it is that not true
have you not heard that am i wrong i
haven't heard that am i wrong
well tell us about the case then because
apparently i'm getting the wrong
information
and yet i don't think i am
so i read that adam was in special
education i don't know if he was like
mentally challenged he was missing for
two days his parents didn't know where
he was and he was with this guy roman
who was 21.
they did a uh wait a minute
he was with a 21 year old
for two days yeah named roman
do you know what i'm thinking
do you know what i'm about to say what
why don't you say it no i don't know
what you're gonna say
was can you get a photo of
roman yeah i'll show you no i'll show
you
because i've been doing work
this is a photo of roman
that's crazy
to me
all right i'm kidding
i've defended this person james charles
by the way i've said let's not jump to
conclusions
so little little diablo or is it baby
diablo
baby diablo or a little homicide or
i mean adam toledo really just something
let's call him his real name
i'm against the cops here can we just
can i say something that the advertisers
might
can we just can we just
shoot the cops that did this
no i'm serious could we let children
shoot the two cops that did it
let other children shoot the cops
they can't remove me for this because
this is my right
i'm expressing my righteous indignation
and rage
because it's woke i there is no one more
woke than myself
let's stop with showing photos of him so
roman i was showing a picture of roman
we just did
so now roman now the problem is roman
roman is he gave him a gun
well roman couldn't have a gun with him
because he was on probation right so i
think the idea was that
he did this this car drove by he fired
eight shots at the car
and then i think he gave the gun to adam
remember when amadou diallo happened
bruce springsteen
uh did a song called 41 shots oh yeah 41
shots didn't that heal
didn't that heal what happened to that
he was a young boy riding on his back
they called him names like baby diablo
in little homicide
but these racist drunk chicago pigs
bacon the smell of bacon in the air
chase them down and out why are you
chasing anyone down an alley
let him go
he's not gonna shoot the obamas
who cares he's gonna shoot another
diablo or a little homicide
he's gonna shoot little bullets
or little knives
i'm just saying i'm kidding
yes you should protect the poor from
each other apparently
but do you see my point are we still
even broadcasting
are we still on this i kind of went off
of this
we're never monetized so i want to go
somewhere else
oh we're definitely not get you i think
you talked about the vaccine in the
first four minutes we're not getting
monetized on this we gotta go
if you've got a service you want us to
come over there you gotta you gotta
spend a little money
but i will go on another service
100 straight up we'll call it
little podcasts
and [ __ ] handy no too i don't you know
what do you want me to say
[ __ ] him i'm sick of him sucks he's i'm
sick of him
he goes in the middle of like a tea
foreign just starts twerking
in like a nazi costume from the cabaret
and then he's like they were very angry
with me
they were mean to me stop twerking
what is the resolution to cop violence
oh um well should i finish to let people
know what happened
yes yes so they ran down the alley
uh adam you've got a big head now
because joe rogan's like
her mom well tim is my mom but bill bird
does it on his own but tomorrow
well we've got a better show
than bill burr's show it's ours is
better whatever can you
what are we gonna do we supposed to
worship all these people to the 98
i'm a [ __ ] and if i had the amount of
[ __ ] in my throat
that other comics have about their
betters or their peers
i would really be gay like the amount
the [ __ ] never leave these people's
throats about just
just struck like
everyone's talking about how good and
but i appreciate what joe said about us
it was very nice
but enough already with everybody you
know we get it everyone's great but
our show is better than the monday
morning podcast he's a better stand-up
to me unquestionably
our show is better that is a fact do you
disagree i agree
and he's the great girl one of the
greatest stand-ups ever much better than
me but
um well you know whatever it's
me is much better but i i was i was kind
of walking back
listen all the respect to him he's a
genius he's the greatest
our podcast is the best thing out there
so
just don't even mention us in the same
name with
other of these people unless they're
willing to get in the weeds with little
ham
because i'm ripping a little harm right
now and no one is
i'm repping the man [ __ ] these [ __ ]
take laurie lightfoot
and get her out of there
not violently not violently not
violently
just respectfully get her out of there
will you tell people what's happening
please and stop
being nervous all the time yeah yeah so
then
they're getting chased they push down
roman another cop jumps on him that cop
keeps running
towards adam adam throws the gun behind
the fence to kind of do like
to do roman a solid it looks like and
then as soon as he turns around and puts
his hands up
he gets shot right and then goes down
dies
so and then they were saying well andy
knows what's different
andy noah has a different version of
this
andy knows version of this is that
adam was in antifa
and they were planning on destroying
the white house and he was running to
the white house
and the cops and he actually
had a direct energy weapon adam he had a
direct energy weapon
that he was using uh to destroy the city
of chicago
and he also had him there was at poor
andy no i don't know if this is true
adam had summoned a massively big
marshmallow man to walk through
chicago and destroy it
and there was a dog and a refrigerator
and there was something called
zul but again this is andy knows
journalism
and he knows journalism
and he knows journalism is that there
was a river of slime running under
chicago
pulsating with people's negative
emotions and thoughts
i'm trying to do this i want the cops in
uh the clink not good
they slandered his name for a week too
they're saying he had a gun in his hand
when he was shot
clearly not true they're the mayor was
saying that
they all lie over there rahm emanuel
lori lightfoot what does that even mean
that named
lightfoot it's a weird name from like
the lord of the rings
bilbo baggins and nori lightfoot
you know samwise gangee and lori
lightfoot
what are we talking of guess you dressed
up like the culvert destroyer right
right covid yeah that was it that's so
stupid
the rona destroyer just small picture we
get a better one
i kind of do i respect that a little bit
what if she did that what if she comes
out in that
to deal with the cops
hey if she comes out here's the thing
i will turn completely for lori ledford
if she comes out dressed like the
riddler
and she just deals with the cops in that
manner